welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
in this video we're breaking down the
finale of the undoing
turns out all along that it was you no
not you
hugh sorry jonathan and if that's all
you've come to find out and
congratulations
you don't have to hear me ramble on for
10 more minutes however
there's also a lot to unpack and discuss
about the ending
as well as the hidden meanings and
metaphors that are laced throughout the
entry
the undoing followed grace as she tried
to unearth the truth about a murder plot
that was centered around her husband
jonathan
after being accused of killing the woman
he'd been having an affair with
grace slowly started to discover the
truth about him throughout the series
in this big whodunit mystery the show
has very much played with the idea of
duality
and the notion that if someone has a
good side then they must in turn have an
equal and opposite bad side which we've
discussed throughout most of our videos
jonathan has been portrayed as the best
of us a child cancer doctor that would
do whatever was necessary for his family
but as discussed he is in fact a monster
now episode 6 picks up immediately after
the reveal that the murder weapon was in
henry's filing
case last week henry admitted to
covering for his father when it came to
the affair with eleanor
and it seems like he did the same thing
when it came to her death
the character discovered the murder
weapon in an outdoor fireplace when they
were at the beach house
but rather than tell his mother he
cleaned it and covered for his dear old
dad
now grace has to grapple with what to do
with this information
and for several weeks we've discussed
how she's been blindsided by jonathan
unable to see him for what he really was
in the first episode she held a therapy
session
in which she discussed how her patient
could not truly comprehend her husband
for the man that he was
and thus their relationship was in some
way built on a lie
this was the same with grace but as she
was a therapist
she was able to see in others and not
herself
however i think she can identify almost
immediately and henry that like her
he's blind to what jonathan is truly
like and this ability to diagnose the
condition in others
makes her realize that it exists within
her and that she has to fight it
grace simply doesn't want her son to
fall victim to jonathan's manipulation
and this almost a-ha like moment and
ability to identify problems in others
makes her recognize her own failings and
act in her family's best interests
she says she wants what's best for henry
and will do whatever is necessary to
make sure that he gets it
now the breaking point for me comes when
jonathan tries to blame their son for
the murder
rather than taking responsibility
himself this
incredibly callous move was of course
echoed in the death of his sister
in which he refused to take any
responsibility for it
even though he caused it he's used to
throwing kids
under the bus literally that's so bad
and he almost does the same thing with
henry who takes him back
like grace has so many times before i'm
sorry about that
under the bus thing it's not not funny
no jonathan takes the stand and comes
across sincere
someone who cures cancer and just a
genuinely
nice british guy who who probably
doesn't make jokes like that
now he calls alanis on his paints
himself out as someone who could never
do such a thing
and tries to excuse taking his tux to
the dry cleaners
even though it's a pretty weird thing to
do if you're in full panic mode
but the case could really go either way
and miguel being put on the stand starts
to spell doom for fernando
however grace knows who the real monster
is and thus she enacts a plan to put him
away for life
she volunteers to be put on the stand
herself stating that she will help to
exonerate the character
but instead she reveals the truth about
his family
and his lack of remorse typically in
american law
testifying like this could be dismissed
as a spouse cannot go against their
partner on the stand
however because the defense called her
up she was able to be cross-examined
and reveal the truth now behind the
scenes this happened because sylvia
went to the prosecution in order to make
a deal to throw jonathan under the bus
grace knew that she had to protect her
son or costs and though henry wanted
nothing more than to be a happy family
again
we all know that it would have led to
more issues down the line
this moment truly paints out jonathan as
being the guilty party
and means that the case can't be thrown
out because it was the defense that
called her up
well sylvia did say that it was always
the husband
but what this does is that it shows that
grace has finally
opened her eyes to what he is and is no
longer blind to what's going on with the
character
the truth shall set you free and in some
ways
it does with us too i think that the
show has done an incredible job of
keeping us guessing over who the real
culprit is
and if you've been coming back to the
breakdowns week after week and you'll
know that it was a long time before we
settled on jonathan as the true killer
however just as grace finally announces
she knows what her husband is like
and franklin confirms it to henry we
ourselves
learn what really happened after the
night of the party we see jonathan
arriving at elena's art studio
which is where he brutally carried out
the crime the reason that jonathan
snapped is because elena tried to build
a friendship with grace
and make everyone part of one big happy
family
now why this caused issues is because as
we've mentioned
there is this duality to the character a
dichotomy in which there is an
evil side which is the part that elena
was with and an opposite side which is
what we've seen with grace
it's a dr jekyll and mr hyde scenario
but as we know
from that tale the two never actually
existed at the same time
and thus could not be brought together
this is reflected in jonathan
who cannot have the good and bad side of
his personality brought to the forefront
because deep down he knows that if the
bat is revealed
then it would mean that he could never
be perceived as good because it would
rock the boat so much
jonathan only really cares about his
legacy and image
and he was willing to do anything in
order to keep this up
his family who knew the truth about him
caused the character to flee
because he was unable to handle people
knowing the way that he really was
this is why he killed eleanor to try and
hide who he was from all around him
and continue living in this dream with
grace in which the pair
seemingly had the perfect life jonathan
says that this
isn't a real him but it is and to me the
fake jonathan was the one we've seen
masquerading as a loving husband and
good father
in the end similar to what happened when
his sister died jonathan tries to run
once more
but this time he takes henry initially
he promises that this will be a
breakfast
before switching the pretense to a road
trip that henry had been longing to go
on
now hugh acts the hell out of this scene
and watching him trying to play happy
families whilst henry looks terrified
allows the actor to slip a slight bit of
insanity
whilst he sits with a smirk on his face
the police close in
but jonathan wants to spend every single
second he can
living this lie as he knows that when
the truth's exposed
the good will be completely forgotten
and he will only be thought of as bad
he drives to the word street bridge
which similar to him
was once held in high regard but since
then it's fallen into disrepair
we hung around after the show and saw
the little interviews that discussed the
ending
then you'll know that the truck almost
hitting them carries a lot of meaning
with it
up until this moment jonathan had not
fully revealed how evil he was
and henry did still trust him to some
extent
however this truck almost cutting
through them severs the ties of their
relationship to the point of no return
jonathan goes to leap from the bridge
but henry rushes to him
showing that he still cares about the
character when jonathan sees his wife
running towards him
in his mind he believes that she's
fallen for him once more
and that he can bring the pair back
under his control as they are trying to
stop him from ending it all
however what grace is actually doing is
going to henry
and henry goes to her rather than
staying with his father
showing that he has made a conscious
choice to step out from under his
control
neither turn around to look at him so he
doesn't get a moment to change their
minds
and with franklin the pair leave
completely cutting all ties with him
whilst he's arrested
in the end we know that jonathan didn't
really love them he loved that they
loved him
and he has to watch as they leave
potentially to season two
now before we get into what happens in
the book beyond this moment
i just want to remind you that we do
videos like this each and every day
so if you're enjoying it so far then
please subscribe to the channel
otherwise i'll throw you under the bus
abso
that's so bad anyway the book keeps the
killer as jonathan
however it does change a number of
things in the source material grace
believed that because of what had been
brought to the forefront
that no one would want to use her as a
therapist to fix their marriage
but she does find purpose in writing a
book that delves into what happened with
jonathan
so that more women can avoid the warning
signs
grace actually goes and connects
directly with jonathan's family
and here she meets his brother mitchell
who adopts the baby that jonathan had
with eleanor
disclaimer as well eleanor in the book
is called malaga
now fernando refused to care for the kid
because it wasn't his
but jonathan's family wanted to take
care of the girl in the hopes of writing
some of the wrongs that jonathan caused
not only to their sibling but also his
family
grace also gets some vindication when
the police come to tell her
that they know she's a good person and
though her husband
was a monster they don't blame her for
it and that's pretty much where things
go
and though the book dives far more into
d hill than i did
hopefully those cliff notes give you a
better idea of where things could be
going
should we get a second season i
definitely think they left things
open-ended for that reason
but i'm not sure how much mystery they
can throw away
when we know that it was j-dog who did
it either way i enjoyed the undoing
and think that everyone really gave a
great performance
the end was a bit weird for me but
that's probably because i'm still
attached to the book
and i was hoping for a big twist or
rather last minute reveal that subverted
my expectations
however i will say that in terms of its
storytelling
and what it was trying to accomplish
that they did a good job
and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the finale and the season as
a whole
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please drop a
thumbs up
and make sure you hang around for our
breakdance of euphoria next week which
will cover the entire show
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the lord of the rings 4k box
set
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of december so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also scrum chapters on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
paul
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you